why is jimmy kimmel not getting the is
he gay no no he hasn't had excess good
[Applause]
today we are guessing which celeb tweets
are real and which ones are fake I'm not
on Twitter really so I think I'm gonna
be bad
I don't tweet much I am pretty common I
took a social media class and they
forced us that's a class yeah social
media journalism
I actually don't follow that many
celebrities on Twitter so I am very
nervous that I'm gonna get most of these
wrong honestly despedido blew up because
of me Justin Bieber I don't know this is
real or not but I could totally picture
Justin Bieber as saying that but also I
know the DES Pacita music video I have
like 2 billion views before Justin
Bieber got onto the song which would
just only confirm that it's a stupid
thing to say he said it you think that's
for sure I honestly almost remember him
saying I'm gonna say that's fake just
because like I desperately need it to be
fake I feel like yeah ok I would have
heard from the lab yeah he may not have
tweeted it but he said it he said it I
would like to send my best wishes to all
even the haters and losers on this
special date September 11th Donald
well that cannot be real which is why I
say it's real oh this one is absolutely
a real tweet let's all take a minute to
really let that set it I'm gonna say
this is false holy [ __ ] nothing Wow
here's my new strategy I'm just gonna go
against my gut if I think it's true it
is absolutely false what's going on with
my career share what's good and there's
no space no she didn't say that this is
a real share tweet I do feel pretty
pretty quickly this is real there's no
space in between the my and career mickr
this word and current career hurry my
career after net so I'm gonna go with
real
[Music]
go against your gut well you can read
this one
suck my you Punk get a TV deal and then
talk to me amateur Charlie Sheen this
does seem like something he would say
I know like he had the whole big public
meltdown right I could see this being a
tweet if it hadn't at ago and fake are
you going to make only because I'm going
true I think it's real
does anyone think global warming is a
good thing I love Lady gaga
I think she's a really interesting
artist Brittany's [ __ ] Spears on the
Internet is my favorite thing did you
combine two tunes by accident look she
did say this I'm sure this is real I'm
sure - that's the problem
have you seen her twirling videos she no
runway videos just like outfits of the
day but has someone filled her and then
she like walks to the camera like twirls
I'm gonna go with real this tweet is
real mmm Jimmy Kimmel put yourself in my
shoes
oh no that means you would have gotten
too much good D in your life Kanye West
this seems so obviously real that I'm
actually worried it's a decoy but I'm
gonna say this is real that Kanye I
didn't say this of course it is
wait I hate that guy do ants have dicks
Kourtney Kardashian I mean a question is
all this time a great question I don't
know the Kardashians are tough for me I
want to say this is false so I'm gonna
say true I feel like this is something
Khloe would tweet yeah I'm gonna guess
that it's not real I'm glad at Kourtney
Kardashian of all people put out that
question into the universe because I
never would have thought of it oh never
going to a Ryan Gosling movie in a
theater again apparently masturbating in
the back row is still considered
inappropriate Anna Kendrick yeah so I
actually do follow Anna Kendrick on
Twitter and she's hilarious the only
thing is this feels like it's almost
going a little too far yeah I think
that's real she's funny she's charming
I'm gonna go with real too because I
want to say it
I think I see this yeah me too bless her
heart she's just like screwing of us and
she doesn't care to hide it
yeah and she's letting us know that we
can't do that I can stop that habit now
okay boys what's your ball flies Nicki
Minaj
I feel like Nicki would say this I don't
think she just outright say this I like
it I'm gonna say this is false
I'd say that's true I don't know I don't
know about this one I'm gonna say just
for fun I'm gonna say yes it's real I
say it's fake though yeah okay yeah we
did I would say that makes us Twitter
experts my social media class did
nothing
I feel pretty good about the BuzzFeed
competition I think it is really
enhanced and occur
[Music]